for example right now current market
people are actively typing in how will a
recession affect real estate what does
the recession mean for me so sometimes
like you get your idea for the hook
right from that like that could be the
hook here's how recession affects real
estate and would you find that even like
a Google search correct a little Trends
from you see Google Trends or you see
the prediction how will recession you
start saying oh the recession related to
home buying is on people's minds yeah
like type in recession you're right the
prediction tells you recession real
estate yeah so then you know to make a
video about that
well I'm fired up for this think media
podcast episode with Neil dingra and
we're going to be talking about how to
make videos go viral the magic formula
and you've gotten millions of views and
you've really developed it into a
three-part viral video framework and the
first part is the hook so uh tell us the
framework and then we'll break down each
piece in this episode yeah so the
framework is you got to start hot we got
to come out with the most value possible
to stop the scroll so you'd imagine
people just scrolling up and down we
gotta stop the thumb so the way to do
that with information is to just give
the best hook and make it appeal to the
most amount of people so you could have
a very narrow topic like a niche topic
based on your industry or whatever
you're talking about but we need to make
that Niche topic have broad appeal so
that's the best type of hook and that's
kind of the first place to start and
when people say like what's the most
important thing that is the most
important thing because without that you
can't even get into the topic so it goes
hook problem solution we'll get to the
other ones in a second so let's break
down the hook you said Niche topic
brought appeal tell people a little bit
about what you do and how your content
could be almost too Niche yes but then
how you brought in it correct so I'm in
the mortgage real estate space and
probably some of the most boring
subjects you know like nobody wants to
learn about home loans and finance uh
but they do want to learn about
Financial Freedom they do want to learn
about the solutions that your product
provides so I think a lot of people talk
about the process and that's great on
YouTube but it's almost DOA on social
because nobody cares about it unless
they're in that Niche they're not
actively searching for that content so
this is Discovery content meaning like
people are just you're just coming up in
the feed you're coming up in the feed so
it's got to be the most valuable content
possible so for me I took these topics
of mortgage real estate and said hey
what is the thing the customer really
wants they want they want to own a home
they want to build wealth they want to
get rich you know they want to avoid
mistakes so I started to take those
topics and make it with a hook that
would cause someone to uh learn about
how they could make money save money or
avoid a mistake and those three rules
like for my hooks ended up creating
hundreds of hooks and that's how you get
more views that's amazing so the
question for the viewer is what would
have the most broad appeal correct what
would go maybe a little bit wider so
that they could reach new people
and then ultimately how do you create a
poignant hook that will grab attention
and then there's some tactics that I
notice you do in your vertical videos
like the first frame is kind of the
thumbnail yeah and you also have kind of
a text hook what is that best practice
especially for Instagram where you
posted yeah that's a really good point
so obviously we're talking about the the
verbal hook what you say it's the first
line out of your mouth in the beginning
of the video there's also an opportunity
for a written hook that appears in the
middle of the screen your eyes are kind
of drawn to it the video pops up
vertically right in the center of the
screen uh for two to three seconds
you've got a written hook and so that's
kind of like it could be exactly what
you said sometimes that's too many words
so you make us you know abbreviated
version of what you said or like if it's
chopped from this podcast we would make
the hook the written hook what the
Hook's going to be but obviously we
didn't say those words so it could be
what you said or it could be just what
you wanted to convey to the viewer now
I've seen the style recently where
people are leaving the hook up for the
entire video and they're just putting it
at the top so that's a trend that we're
starting to see work for some creators
but for the most part you want to have
that written hook up three seconds so
people can visually see it they can hear
what you're talking about and then they
decide to stop scrolling maybe give you
their attention for a few seconds if you
got them hopefully you can keep their
our attention so you've got the written
hook on screen therefore one of the
skills to develop is how to concisely
communicate powerful ideas that get
attention you could actually one of my
favorite things to do is Google
headlines like best headline formulas
um digital marketer I'm speaking at an
event called TNC they're they're they
have great articles on like top 50
headlines and you can kind of copy and
paste it's kind of a way of thinking
yeah in marketing it's called
copywriting right and so having those
powerful
headlines may or may not be the literal
thing you're saying but on screen you
want it to be simple and easy to
understand and I've heard too you also
want to kind of avoid
um complexity and best practice is like
a fifth grade or less reading level yeah
so I saw one that was fourth grade right
so fourth grade so how to get rich or
three tips for getting rich well that
makes sense to me yeah but if it was
like you know three tips on how to bonus
depreciate real estate yeah it's a good
Niche thing for people who understand
but you might miss them or if you're
using terminology so you want as broad
of of appeal as possible
tell me your process before we get to
the rest of the formula if you're
sitting down and planning for a shoot
day where you're going to be creating
these videos yeah are you scripting your
videos word for word are you just
outlining them and are you writing those
hooks yourself or do you have someone
helping you now that's able to use those
good headlines come up with those good
headlines what's like a workflow of how
many videos you do at once and how you
create them yeah so I would separate the
writing from the shooting so a lot of
times people sit down to shoot videos
but you don't know what you're gonna say
you know what you're gonna do you waste
your time right so I want to be
intentional about what I'm doing so for
the writing part I will sit down
research topics that are trending what
are consumers searching for like Google
Trends answer the public you know
finding those things and then of those
ideas then starting to think of like
just working on the hook so I write them
myself and then as for the rest of the
video
um you know we'll collaborate the team
and I sometimes will just throw ideas
around like how maybe how does this
sound guys or we'll just start writing
together and and for the most part we'll
write out what we want to say but we may
deviate from that in the video because
we wanted to not sound like super
scripted Super Robot so the hook is
definitely scripted like that line is
set in stone but the next lines you
could just speak freely if you're if you
feel comfortable with it some people
like knowing exactly what they're going
to say so they could put on a
teleprompter but for the most part what
I do is I make sure I know the hooks and
then I have bullet points on what I'm
going to say and I try and just keep it
concise I think like the best performing
reels for me are you know under
definitely under a minute sometimes uh
35 seconds or less have been the ones
that did the best for me amazing and so
the next
part of the formula is the problem what
is that so it's like you know it's it
could be in your hook or it could be
something separate so I'll give you an
example for real estate for example like
you know the the hook is
you know here's a big mistake I see
young home buyers making
the problem is they're waiting until
they have 20 down to buy their first
home
solution do this instead and then I talk
about hey paying PMI is not that big of
a deal super cheap if you have good
credit and it's actually going to make
you money rather than waiting and during
that time prices go up you know so I put
in the hook is basically to get them
into the video and then I tell them the
problem they're facing and then give my
solution now sometimes the hook could
actually have the problem built into it
like you know this is a
um you know this is a huge mistake to
avoid or here's the top three things you
need to do and then you just go directly
into your solution so it doesn't
necessarily have to be a separate step
but sometimes it can be gotcha so the
problem Help The Listener understand
um are you trying to agitate a problem
is the whole video kind of based around
solving a problem especially in the
education Niche if you're teaching
something
um in any other lessons you've learned
about problem yeah so you think about
um if you made a t-chart you know
problems and solutions so if you're in
any business what are the problems your
clients face how do you solve those
problems so those problems that your
clients face are things that they're
actively searching for solutions for
online they're literally typing it into
Google like for example right now
current market people are actively
typing in how will a recession affect
real estate what does the recession mean
for me so sometimes like you get your
idea for the hook right from that like
that could be the hug here's how a
recession affects real estate and would
you find that even in like a Google
search correct a little chance you see
Google Trends or you see the prediction
how will recession you start saying oh
the recession related to home buying is
on people's minds yeah like type in
recession you're right the prediction
tells you recession real estate yeah so
then you know to make a video about that
and then you know magically that video
gets way more views than the one that
you know you didn't use that headline
okay so help me make a viral reel so I
help people with YouTube and so problems
um I don't know how to start it's a
little broad I don't know how to make a
video I don't know how to make a
thumbnail
um I don't know uh what camera to buy so
those are some problems and then the
solution I could give it how could I
sauce up those hooks yeah so on YouTube
um you know you're talking
about general questions that clients
have or people or viewers have now if
you're in a position where you have
specific knowledge on how you did this
or your clients did this to make the
hook even more powerful you can say
here's how I did this or here's how I
here's how I made 1.7 million dollars
with my YouTube channel last year yes
that's a great hook right here's how my
client got here's how my client got two
million views on their third month or
what you know whatever like if I were to
do it for reels I would say you know
here's how I grew an audience to a
hundred thousand in six months or in
nine months or whatever your whatever
your achievement was you could throw it
in there powerful it's super powerful
because it's real yeah now if you don't
quite have those results yet that's okay
you can just be an Enthusiast you don't
have to flex but so then you could say
here's how you can so here's how you can
blow up your YouTube channel in 12
months or less and then you get into it
you know so I think I think you want to
put what they really want in that hook
first that makes so sense so if the
problem is I want to make money with a
small audience rather than being so on
the nose I could say here's how I made
twenty two thousand dollars last month
in affiliate yeah because you have to
think like why do they want a YouTube
channel they want to be YouTube famous
they want to make money they want a
better lifestyle here's how to improve
the quality of your life yes here's how
you can quit your job with YouTube so
quit your job is the hook yes then if
the problem is make money on YouTube but
you can hook it so many different ways
and you said that earlier you said you
kind of could have sometimes come up
with a hundred hooks yeah so and the
thing that's funny is like as we're
talking right now we get into a mode
where we could just write 100 hooks
right now because it just clicks and
then you start to roll so that's what
happens to me anyways I don't know if
I'm unique but that's the way I start
writing them and then I come up with a
bunch and it's actually fun because
you're hacking attention it's like a
video game Instagram like how do we stop
the thumb well let's try it this way no
let's try it this way let's put the hook
here you know and then you start to see
what works then you replicate
are you ready to start or grow your
YouTube channel do you feel stuck and
need help connecting the dots join this
free web class where you'll learn the
step-by-step playbook for YouTube
success we've helped thousands of
purpose-driven entrepreneurs just like
you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com
so I want to talk a little bit about you
know where are we going to go next and
what's this all lead to but the first
part of your three-part viral video
formula is the hook the second part is
the problem and then the solution is
something that you're teaching what
other tips do you have on solution or
just let's make that concrete for The
Listener yeah I think you need to give
real solutions but not make it so
complex so a lot of times the mistake
creators make is you got a 30 to 60
second video you're trying to pack a lot
of information in there it's hard to do
that on a reel now you could direct them
to the YouTube video where you give the
full strategy and you could put that in
your caption so I think for most
creators the solution is going to be
give them some tangible advice that
would really help them but don't overdo
it and then when in doubt just expand in
the caption so the caption could say
expand on it and then direct them to a
longer form video on YouTube if you have
it and that's the best way to do that so
you know for me I try and just educate
them on one thing because it's going to
be difficult to add a bunch of Topics in
30 40 seconds and also one of the things
I noticed that gets you a lot of views
is getting the people to complete the
video
so better way to I mean just to increase
your odds of completing the video you
make a shorter video shorter that's easy
so for you where are you uploading is
Instagram your Main Place yeah so I'm
doing Instagram and then I'm repurposing
the content on Tick Tock YouTube shorts
LinkedIn and then now Facebook reels as
well and so which one is the best to
rank them in order for getting results
for you you're doing real estate
mortgage uh money advice investing what
are best performing for you in order it
just depends on your goals so I know a
lot of people love Tick Tock right now
because they're blowing up on Tick Tock
I haven't gotten much business
opportunity from Tick Tock so it hasn't
been a focus of mine I really love
Instagram because it leads to uh this
community that you can build on direct
messages so for me the cool thing about
Instagram is Instagram's trying to catch
up with Tick Tock so they're actively
telling creators hey produce more reels
we're going to give you free reach so
they're pushing your content for free
and I don't know how long that lasts but
the cool thing about Instagram is now
that you build this community if you
engage with people now they'll do
business with you so I'm just trying to
have more conversations the best way
best platform for me to have more
conversations is on Instagram because
they see the stories they see the feed
content that leads to conversations in
the DMS a lot at least the deals flow
you can't do that on YouTube right now I
don't know the ins they have direct
messages on on Tick Tock but it's not
very it's just not user friendly it's
not really working it's a lot of spam so
the best place for me to start would be
there and uh you know you might get more
traction on one of the other platforms
so that's why I say to start creating
there and then repurpose it elsewhere I
think a lot of creators start on Tick
Tock but then their branded videos are
Tick Tock and I think the other
platforms don't like that with that logo
and you have to like remove it first
what are you seeing happen on Facebook
and Linkedin for you so I I figured hey
I've already got the video I've gone
through the trouble of riding the hook
coming up the script shooting it
producing it posting it now I'm having
in the beginning it was me but now I'm
having my assistant just take that same
video put it on Facebook reels Facebook
reels are blowing up now all of a sudden
because Facebook's post is promoting the
same thing LinkedIn I don't get as much
traction but I still reach people that I
would not reach elsewhere so I've
noticed on LinkedIn people on that
platform you'll find that are on no
other platform
so they're not active social users
they're just only on LinkedIn so for
example I've connected with like
attorneys and those types of people and
the only way of what they would have
found me was on LinkedIn so you may as
well put it up and so LinkedIn reels are
they available to everybody there's no
reels it's just in feed video so you're
just uploading a vertical video in
vertical video in feed on LinkedIn it's
not going to get promoted like it is on
the other platforms but it still does
well gotcha and then what are you
experiencing with YouTube shorts you're
repurposing the same videos yeah so I
think YouTube shorts is the same thing
they're trying to promote those and get
and catch up for me I haven't seen my
YouTube shorts blow up yet because I
haven't focused on it but I know other
creators in our groups and programs that
we talk to that are getting a ton of
traction on YouTube shorts with the same
exact video so
um I think you can you know definitely
try different things it seems like the
raw podcast like cut from long form does
better on YouTube than it does on
Instagram so there's little nuances to
like each one but if you don't want to
go ahead and create like uh directly for
each platform I would just start with
one start with one and so basically your
system is you're planning and preparing
all your videos shooting them in batches
correct and then once you have them you
can distribute them across five
different platforms at that point you
don't really have anything to lose
you're playing on house money if
Instagram's working for you the four
other platforms are only possible more
reach more personal brand more growth
yeah and then you can also do other
types of content on those platforms so
for example I like to create a short
version of the video for Instagram and
all these platforms and then a longer
version of that topic where you can go
deeper and put that up on YouTube so if
you teach three tips for buying a home
or investing in real estate or something
you've Consolidated it down to a less
than 60 second version and are you
staying under 60 seconds so that your
platform Universal because Tick Tock
lets you go longer Facebook might be
shorter I think you have to get so do
you just stay under 60 seconds yeah I do
for sure because I've just noticed those
perform better because we get more
completion is easier to retain people
but if you plan out a vertical video
that is under 60 seconds that may turn
into a YouTube video that expounds on
the points correct so you could just go
deeper because you're not really giving
much information you're just giving
really quick headlines and then you
could make an eight minute video of that
for YouTube and it will do well now it
may not go viral but that doesn't matter
at this point so the final thing I want
to land the plane on is by committing to
creating content like this what was your
journey in terms of how this grew you
mentioned six months like how much
outputs how much time in your week you
have a whole business to run so what did
you commit to and what was sort of just
the nuances of that curve if someone's
listening to this uh you know you
definitely can't guarantee the same
results but you could probably guarantee
results like you start doing the work
you start putting out vertical videos
you you are thoughtful about the hook
the problem the solution but it's not
going to be without work talk about the
amount of time work kind of like was it
slow at the start then it started to
pick up
um in the Journey of you doing this yeah
I think in the beginning people are you
know I don't have time for Content
because they don't see that the
content's actually going to save you
time so every business owner or anybody
in sales has a certain time they
dedicate to prospecting this replaced
all the prospecting time for me because
now it's more inbound so in the
beginning I would uh just have to juggle
more so you know you just allocate the
time so I would just tell people to put
it on their schedule so I just make the
time for writing as if it was an
appointment as if it was this podcast
it's on the calendar you got to do it
and then the time to shoot now you have
your scripts ready to go you can just go
into the lab and shoot and I think if
you do it in an efficient way it doesn't
have to take up so much time and other
thing is is like
most strategies the reason why people
quit is because they don't get any
traction so you go to the gym two weeks
in you're like I'm not getting ripped so
I quit you know what's the point but
like in this this is one area where you
could start to see Traction in the first
30 days and so when you start to see
that and you start to get the traction
it becomes like oh I like this I'm
actually getting somewhere like somebody
reached out to me or I'm building an
audience and it's fast and I think when
this today's like 80d culture getting
some results going is probably the best
way for you to get committed to the
strategy and now you're actively like
wanting to put more of that time on the
calendar because you're seeing the
benefit sooner than you would have like
a couple years ago I didn't even there
was no way to go viral on Instagram or
you know Tick Tock it wasn't there so
now that you have this opportunity I
think it's gonna incentivize you to do
it more and from the start did you
invest in other people helping you
uh no I saw in the beginning I would
just shoot him then I would be spending
two hours at night editing them and it
was just like you know if you're running
a business now it's getting you're just
it's not the highest and best you use of
your time So eventually it started
Outsource the edit so I think what would
be a great framework for people to use
is to find a place where you could shoot
these videos get your equipment dialed
in if you want to shoot with a phone
that's great we have students in our
groups that shoot with just cell phones
just get the light and the audio dialed
and get a good you know get a good setup
going and then shoot those videos and
upload them to an editor because you
spending the time chopping them up
putting the title in the text and doing
all this is like you know it's going to
take you a lot of time and it might keep
you from creating that might be the
bottleneck so if I shoot 10 videos in a
batch
give them to the editor now a week later
I got a folder on Google Drive with 10
videos ready to post yeah and I can just
keep that going and not get bogged down
in the edit because I've seen a lot of
creators they're like I don't want to
Outsource the edit because I only do it
the best and then it becomes a
bottleneck because you're adding like
one at a time or two at a time and
you're not posting enough if someone's
listening to this and they're making
fifty to eighty thousand dollars a year
running their own business or working in
another job trying to build out this
side hustle
um
what would you say about investing in
your business like this they're going to
put in The Sweat Equity from sitting
down shooting buying some accessories
for their phone buying a light kit now
they're shooting the videos how much is
it going to cost for them to edit if
they upload that and what justification
would you encourage that listener to uh
for why they should invest well I think
you know you you're in a certain
position in life because you're playing
a game which is uh very linear you know
you put in this amount of work and you
get this amount of money
and what's cool about building a
personal brand and putting out content
building an audience is their upside is
unlimited right so there's very few
things you can invest in that have that
type of upside you know imagine putting
money into like early stage company
that's you in this case you're the early
stage stock and it doesn't cost you a
dime in the beginning it could just cost
you the time maybe a little bit of money
but in that case like now you have a
return that's not symmetric to the
amount you put in so you put an amount
of time your return could be massive so
when you start thinking in those terms
now you see like hey this there's
there's opportunities coming for you
that you don't even know yet and I
didn't know many of the opportunities I
have today would come from just putting
on content and building an audience like
even just being here with you right the
only reason that happened is because of
putting out videos and you had to start
somewhere so I think in the beginning
people
um just don't really connect those dots
they want to instant Roi but just know
that there's some big things out there
based on examples of other people who
have come before you if people want to
connect with you follow you online check
out what you're doing and where you're
at so the best places on Instagram at
Neil home
boom Neil thank you thank you
[Music]